now Japanese and Filipinos were cutting
grass and then the Mexicans took our
jobs
I mean I mean faster
what you want a circle or a square
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
the careful boys today we have Mr Jesus
yes sir
[Applause]
homie in the Discord goes by the name of
apple
89757 and you can only ask these
questions if you're part of the patreon
so make sure you join our patreon to
join our conversations and ask us
questions that's right and our lives
check it out yeah so he this guy he he
always has a lot of stuff to contribute
so you might hear his name a lot but
today he wanted to know
let's say that we had to exist in a
totally different time period when would
that be and what would you be like easy
uh I already thought about this what my
favorite time Tang Dynasty
my favorite time period is um has always
been early 90s oh wow laptop New Jack
Swing [__] colorful ass clothes and
pants and racial slurs are okay
you know they're actually cassette
cassette tapes and races
bullied in the 90s pretty people pretty
bad really bad freaking um riots you
guys are attacked pretty hard yeah oh
yeah we got to have guns at the liquor
stores kind of cool I got you but you
guys are trying nice eye for an eye I
guess similar simpler times are we are
we the same uh ethnicity and everything
we're the same person but it just
depends on which era yeah yeah but you
could also be a great way
but it wouldn't be black though like
you would have or what type of social oh
it doesn't have to be really like what
you're who you are now kind of no that
would be possible because it's made by
this era I'm gonna let you guys go but I
know I already know I think about it
every day where would you what city
would you be living in though
L.A I loved L.A I loved Atlanta damn
okay
yeah I loved Ellen and I think back then
there was so few Asians
you just have to do a little bit and you
stood out and you were the guy you know
I mean like back then like even with
streetwear now right like you have Bobby
hundreds is forever
industry where boom yeah like even like
uh Richard Aoki and black panthers I'm
sure there's other Asians but you just
have to be just a little bit and it's
like oh he's the Asian guy that started
Benihana's are they dead whatever there
you don't have to do too much you just
gotta do a little bit start very hard so
you just pop like now you got so many
people gotta compete against you know
how am I gonna compete against seeing
moo he's all sexy and [__] and he just
did music
yeah
I think and doing music yeah Rich Brian
you got Jackson Wang you got all these
[__] it's impossible not just
Jackson but Wang but back then you just
gotta do it
I mean you only had to compete against
Jackie Chan oh that's true and he's over
there yeah it's barely wait does it have
to be in America no it's anywhere up to
you yep right that Marina doesn't even
do karate and he's the [__] sensei in
karate kid that's true you never seen a
new karate at all that's what I'm saying
you just need to do a little bit so
what's yours what's yours mine's no dude
50s 50s 50s I like the [__] Greaser
[__] suits
I like that I like the simpler
cigarettes in the sleeves cigarettes in
the sleeves I would be the guy [__]
like with the hair and everything with
the [__] little pompadour uh uh
members only jacket the things I was
just [__] fight because I would love
to like be in fights and knowing that no
one's gonna shoot me or anything it's
just like
it was like yeah be that [__] guy at
the pool hall just [__] picking on
[__] and [__] you can have a [__]
and every [__] State because they
don't have social media they don't
[__] yeah they're not families dude
around you just uh you start a family at
12 years old you know what I mean just
have a business I'd be working in like a
construction like a lumber yard and just
looking to get money's so attractive and
uh gosh I just like the [__] idea
it's simple we work hard you you work
hard and then you go [__] have some
beers and [__] it just you know dude
yeah you're right nice if I see a hot
girl I would go in there and actually
talk to her and like like the the thrill
of like trying to like Chase for a girl
is like fun for me I was like yo that'd
be fun now it's like
you get too many of them I just like I
like it when I see it I'm like yo that
like the early 90s was kind of like that
in a way a little bit it was a little
bit I wasn't an adult but like when I
wanted to talk to a girl like in high
school like in high school or middle
school I was at the mall and I would
just go up to her I'll just go talk I
would literally have to go out there and
talk to her and all my friends were like
she's like no you're ready I was not
that guy you know what's crazy I think
you're beautiful 90s is 30 years away
from the 60s just as far as it it's away
from right now wait what because it's
30. so 90s is 30 years away from now and
but 90s was also just 30 years away from
the 60s so it's actually the same
distance which was like four into our
brain so the 90s is our 60s but 60 yeah
but 60s feels so far away that does feel
long right well that's the 60s right
kids today yeah isn't that crazy yeah so
I would like that I like to go to diners
and just like you know yeah you put a
nickel in the Jukebox and then you look
at the chick that you like because you
played this yeah you know what I mean
just play some [__] oh man
[Music]
I think you would do better in the 50s
than we would though yeah I mean Asians
would have it too [__] hard
yeah
get that engine out of here
Mexicans had a pretty good Community
already at that point though yeah I
guess you're right well what are you
talking about Asians and the Mexicans
kind of like were the same yeah but we
won't be able to enjoy a lot of the
things you think so because you guys
already got Desi right Desi Arnaz like
he's already on TV where the [__] do we
got dude what did you guys have no in
the 50s we have Bruce Lee oh wait no
Bruce Lee
let me switch that up
okay you guys you guys were agents were
very smart
no no are very smart I think about in
the 50s they're worse we're in the 50s
don't twist my [__] words buddy but
because we were over here just [__]
working paying the house you guys were
buying businesses you guys created your
own little Community now we were picking
strawberries bro working this long
alongside [__] [__] have businesses
like look at my private Chinese that's
the Chinese that was in the 50s you guys
owned that [__] in the 50s no Japanese
and Filipinos were cutting grass and
then the Mexicans took our jobs
I mean if we did it faster
we're kind of better hey you guys were
doing some [__] decorating [__] like
look at that [__] out of here decorating
you guys are just trying to [__] make
it outside the horses
[Music]
what you want a circle
[Laughter]
and you would still be in LA in the 50s
uh La would be cool I would like to like
some like place like the Footloose area
it would be in a small town but a small
town dude I would Thrive at a small town
I'd rather be a king at a small town a
little [__] peasant than a [__]
large town you know what I mean I want
to be you know how many times too let me
tell you something right now I didn't
know how many times in school I've
daydreamed of like what if one day I
move into like a small town and you're
like the king and I'm like [__] guy and
every all the guys there are ugly and
I'm just the hottest guy there and it's
all like hot ass girls but you know what
I mean like it's a small town because
I've been I've been to these small towns
you ever go to like Disneyland and you
see how that [__] you're like oh she's
[__] hot with this like jabroni ass
dude yeah but because they're from but
[__] nowhere because they're from but
[__] no he was the hottest guy in her
Town yeah and you're like oh this is
like hot as you can do but when you go
to like a you know big city you're like
you're around [__] it
but I've seen this at Disneyland
together and I heard them going like
they lived in like Kansas or something
like yeah oh like they got together in
high school yeah she didn't keep looking
good she kept getting hotter and hotter
yes and you're like how does this couple
work I daydream about me doing that like
one day like if my parents like moved
and I was like the hottest guy there and
always go I have to just turn your girls
down like nah I appreciate it but no
thanks like we can [__] but I don't know
and it never happened but I daydreamed
about that [__] in the 50s that would be
a lot easier to do yeah no but they're
more conservative and they [__] less
yeah but dude he wasn't the right guy
you had to go the 60s there was [__] in
the 50s dude yeah
you know you got a little just charm
that I hope you like saggy titties and
hairy [__]
let me tell you something
I'll just be over there cleaning my car
and [__] just [__] that's all you had
to do yeah he's working on something
yeah working on the engine yeah just
looking you know just [__] show some
tricep okay then the girl walks by like
wow
the girls just like oh my God
hey guys I think you got to figure it
out
Joe where would you be I would be don't
say feudal Japan no
I would be a Bronze Age Merchant
what is that what is it because all
right like in the Bronze Age right like
I would say like I would like to see
[__] Egypt [__] before it got all
[__] up yeah you know what I mean I
want to see like ancient China I want to
see all that [__] before all the
cultures started like copying each other
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just gonna say
that too yeah I want to go down to
[__] Cambodia when Angkor Wat was
still in action like all these ancient
culture trading was like like they were
still trading and [__] right but then
like the cultures were so distinctly
different yeah yeah and then just seeing
how humans like here are living like
this and then like you go over here and
you just like it's a different world
yeah it's a different [__] world that
would be yeah pre-colonialism yeah
that'll be that'll be interesting that's
pretty cool actually yeah I would I
would live in feudal Japan just because
it's an Asian country but they had like
some really different like ideas you
would die inside yeah
really you'd probably die pretty fast
they were killing each other left and
right beautiful Japan and they were like
the best Swordsmen too like they were
like I swear there was like it's like
Medieval Times Like Japanese like like
the Ninja Turtles like when they went to
Japan exactly like that yeah
I like that but yeah but no I like it
the time where there was like Samurai
around you know and like sword the
blacksmith would make swords and stuff
yeah you could be a blacksmith they'll
probably won't kill you or or like I
don't know I don't know what my
profession would be but I definitely
would want to see what the world was
like before that would be cool yeah but
also that would be the suckiest way to
die in a sword fight oh yeah dude but
you died I [__] the honor
all those people that died with honor
you think anyone remembers them today so
what was that odd or word who gives a
[__] this [__] guy knows what yeah
you step on someone's shoes and they
just slice your head off it's either
funeral Japan or a round when the Silk
Road was forming where uh when the
different cultures were starting to
merge like just the very beginning
that'd be cool yeah would you be
Japanese or would you be Vietnamese I
would be Vietnamese oh yeah but but
hey you got two swords dude find it out
they had their own
um thing I think they had another
government it wasn't called Vietnam it
was called Champa or something and then
they were connected with Cambodia yeah
and Laos oh wow I see yeah it's just a
different time back then so I wouldn't
want to see like how how did people live
back then when when they're starting to
be like imagine the first Asian person
meeting the first European yeah
but then they shook hands get horribly
sick you get sick you get the black
plague dude you imagine being the first
person yeah you get super sick they
don't shower get in shower yeah I like
that I like what you're saying that is
very interesting of like finding seeing
the first time yeah but maybe and it
also like the [__] the the pyramids I
would love to see how that should while
it's going on yeah oh wow the slaves are
still working I know you're like so it
is slaves that's how they did it oh no
another one would have been uh Jesus
time when he was alive so you could see
if he was a person or for real because
to see the first like levels you're like
hey by the way but that's gonna look so
hard like everybody's gonna still talk
about this [__] he's doing it dude and
write those gibberish [__] up top people
are gonna freak the [__] out dude it's
gonna be sick yeah
you want to be with Jesus in his homies
so so I would want to be alive around
the time like all the biblical stuff was
happening but you want to be around
Jesus to be like oh you're real
or something like around a figure that
now it's like how we can never know if
they were realized oh Ron Hubbard like
that he's gonna tell Jesus yo Latinos
are gonna put you on their walls yeah
it's crazy they're gonna draw you all
wrong
yeah they're gonna draw you all
different with long hair what if you
could do it and he literally goes oh hey
Ken oh dude right when you get there
he's like what are you doing here what
would you do what would Jesus do what
would I do what would you do if he if he
saw me and knew I would be like whoa
this trip it's like running into your
daddy's strip club huh what are you
doing here huh what are you doing here
would you go to
1970s Singapore you know what that's I
was actually thinking like that would be
kind of tight this should be around in
the area around the time that moment it
became its own country so I could see
where my mom and my dad met and I'm just
kidding
stop it from happening stop it you guys
can't do this I don't know why you guys
can keep fighting I just start
disappearing what the [__]
um I think I'd be riding horseback dude
just marched along a giant army and I
look over and I see my
commander-in-chief [__] Genghis bro
and we're riding into it
you look like a [__] Warrior dude
dude you want to be a Mongolian it would
be crazy to see like obviously you know
they did a bunch of you know pillaging
and killing a lot of people but I think
it might be interesting to see like it
was right back then yeah that's that's
that's big business back then yeah
that's your conglomerate right there
that's your [__] but don't try to
invade Japan on song I'm saying you guys
gonna lose because then the water's
washed throughout history no but just to
see like I think that would be so fast
because I am fascinated by all the the
Mongolians and the Huns and all that
stuff like just to hear about the
history and how they just took over the
whole goddamn company did he have like a
shitload of babies and [__] okay can I
say something it might sound races yeah
no I'm [__] that's it say it dude is
that why Asians look alike
I didn't want to
what it's probably a good shot that's
probably why yeah the genetics are the
same yeah good shot yep I mean
science behind it at least yeah
but like a real answer for me to like
actually live and have a life I think it
would be somewhere in like the 80s dude
yeah 80s really I don't know like how
old would you be in the 80s like 20
years old in the 80s 30 years old yeah
that's what I would want to be yeah it
is I just think to the Future too and
just music music in general I think
music hits me forever technology is
coming like a new stuff electric still
first came in like synthesizers and
stuff like that I want to be Miami Vice
in the 80s was dangerous yeah right yeah
yeah but I want to be in that show like
I want to be one of the cops
I wouldn't mind living in like uh like
an 80s but like a Midwestern town in the
80s I'm saying I was thinking about that
why why Midwestern time they wouldn't
watch your Filipino ass there but you
could be racing ambiguous I would like
it just maybe uh I don't know why I like
the idea of like living in those like
you know like where they have like ski
resorts like hot dogs like Kodiak
mountains I like that [__] yeah there's
something somewhere kind of naturey
right yeah but in the 80s and they have
seasonal like influx of people and they
leave right I like like you know how
Yellowstone and [__] like that show I
want something like that like where it's
like cowboy [__] oh yeah I have my own
land and my own [__] you know yeah
but at least it looks cool like Mexican
like white you look cool at doing that
[__] Asians in the cowboy outfits it
just doesn't matter it just doesn't go
yeah yeah I'm sorry Shanghai Noon
I'll tell you a guy that changed my mind
let me show you there's something
there's certain things that that
Mexicans like if you see them they just
it's not that deep voice I'll show you a
guy because a Mexican and a cowboy boo
it's it's it works it works it fits like
a glove because you're using the
Rancheros but yeah an Asian dude in a
[__] cow we should all be like nah I
need to wear a samurai suit on a horse
benefits that'd be gangster let me see
no I'm surprised you didn't say you
wanted to be a pirate back in the day
where you were in living on an island or
something uh he's Asian adjacent
what's agent adjacent yeah like Hawaiian
or something you know Hawaiians are like
half Japanese half Filipino have some
things you know how weird they are
they look like Chinese but they're not
really Chinese let me see where's it
who's this Asian Cowboy you're trying to
find dude oh there's a picture with me
that's not a good picture oh that dude
this guy
he's a cowboy
yeah he's he rocks again
yo what about 90s in Japan
he's uh that might have been tight yeah
well I mean he's Hawaiian that's why I
said he's like adjacent uh he's a killer
he's a Asian adjacent I feel like oh is
she one of the dudes that Tim he works
with Tim so he runs Tim's like
combatives program Tim Kennedy's like he
passed all the way around over there but
he rocks a cowboy ass sick he looks very
cool he does look cool and he looks like
he looks like he can kill you yeah he
can kill you I grappled with him he
killed me
he looks good and he's like Asian
adjacent he looks more Polynesian
S
I want to talk about like Asian when you
look at him like Asian right off the bat
God damn it that's an Asian man right
there like in a cowboy suit and that
beer dude yeah well dude it's crazy
yeah I want him I want him to look like
his name is Angus Wong or something yeah
something with the long at the end kind
of hard did you say yours Bart did you
say yours 90 90s oh I would join you in
the night I remember I don't remember it
I would join you in the 90s as a cast of
Baywatch
oh yup that'd be tight yep I do miss the
90s sometimes but
not like that like I lived it like what
like honey honey I love the kids
living in as an adult
yeah that might be kind of tight
Homeward Bound you ever watch that
homework watch your homework 90s was
like the Pinnacle of like uh cheap
action flicks too yeah oh yeah that's
when like they they made so many of them
when I think of 90s I think of like the
iconic places in La like Venice Beach
Santa Monica Hollywood Hip Hop that's
cool because you guys grow up here yeah
yeah but when I think of the 90s I think
of La I can't think of anywhere else and
I think of uh I think of the Pinnacle of
suburb life before it took the 90s yeah
that's true yeah that's true like the
three ninjas yeah that's kind of like
Palmdale when it was first built yeah
and like kids playing on the street yeah
and that was cool yeah 3 Ninjas was so
hard that movie
when you think of that you think of like
Diamond bar or Rancho Cucamonga like all
the all those new [__] developments
outside of L.A
yeah dude yeah you see in the 90s Friday
nights like tonight today it'll be like
Blockbuster yeah yeah let's go to
Blockbuster [__] uh Pizza Hut yeah
the pizza coupons and it was like the
way it worked in my family it was like
one movie for the kids uh we get to
choose the movie we want for us and my
parents choose the movie that they want
to watch in their room and stuff and
then a movie for all of us
so lost share the family movie watch
that sometimes we're just like all right
keep it going because we're ready to
watch so we're ready to watch [__]
American Pie like hurry up Dad and they
didn't know like you know immigrant
parents they don't know what we're
watching yeah so we're watching American
Pie we're learning about like all this
[__] you know like when I was watching
American Pie that scene where she's like
blowing up and then throws it in the cup
and that's I didn't know what she was
doing I was like what is that
what's going on yeah I didn't get it I
didn't understand what was going on why
is she kissing him yeah do you get it
now
you guys remember like the book clubs if
you read a book and you got like a free
Pizza Hut like coupon and you get a
personal Pizza yeah yeah dude what a
promotion I remember that [__] well you
go to pizza and they give you a little
personal Pizza yo I need to get a pizza
we were lucky to have the 90s Pizza when
we did I know 90s was like you know if I
would have known things were gonna
change so much I would have enjoyed it a
little bit more we were lucky to have
life without internet like we were the
ones that uh were there we're the last
people we saw I told my I told my
brother this and he was like telling me
like I was like dude I was there when
when it started like we got to see the
internet start there was no internet and
then there was internet like it TV in
the 90s was the best for sure yeah TV in
the 90s was the best except for those
damn commercials what were you watching
in the night which we'll never forget
now the [__] Fox like oh dude I was
watching Mad TV yeah at a young age I
was watching Mad TV there's a bunch
which one South Park I never [__]
herself South Park was late though well
that was that was cable too yeah I
wasn't really into it
Celebrity Death Match oh yeah TRL and
then [__] PRL no 90s is more like
Baywatch and then um Warner Brothers
with all the yeah Steve urkels and the
yeah yeah a sitcom family with Mr Cooper
no oh Hercules I think of Hercules
I never liked those those are two I
never watched it but I would see I was
really into [__] the Texas Rangers
Texas [__] Ranger Chuck Norris Chuck
Norris I think of Sinbad movies and I
think of hanging with Mr Cooper Renegade
the crazy Terminator movies were on TNT
dude
Terminator Charles Bronson yeah it's
kind of funny like the idea of watching
a movie on TV yeah oh yeah by
commercials like No One's Gonna see that
again right yeah remember to get the TV
guy yeah because then you're like oh
it's gonna be on like 7 30 we gotta like
oh you planned your day through that you
had a plan a day do you remember tevo
oh yeah and it was like it was like the
most expensive thing so it was like
everything oh I got a teapot oh you got
a Tebow yeah
I blew my mind when that came out I was
like dude it's scheduled yeah my dad
would be at the store and be like
TV shows
sometimes we will like forget to get
like eggs because we're dead like look
at the [__] eggs we're gonna watch
the movie at the house that's what I
miss is everyone used to just watch
together like live TV or something went
down everyone was on the TVs together at
the same hour same time I even liked
watching movies from the middle you know
that you turn on the TV oh [__] what the
[__] what is this Billy the Kid yeah and
you're just like watching it
look at the barbershop
like it's all kind of hilarious I didn't
even know Bloodsport had a beginning
Montage I showed him oh dude
after the
after that watch yeah yeah
yes
we're Dumb and Dumber like I forgot they
were they were in an aspen I'm like oh
that was like a chunk yeah
I never saw that first part but uh going
back to Bloodsport have you guys seen it
like recently yeah dude
holds up but it's so wild like it's just
like the the
thing in the beginning with the kid yeah
you're not gonna call the cops it's like
it's so terrible
oh dude and then there was this one
scene where like he's [__] that girl
and it's just a weird shot of his ass
yeah like why is
they say like
like we action and he's just like
like he says
he lifts it up yeah and I'm just like
bruh why was that why is there more of
him than the girl a lot back then
there's a lot of assets his older movies
he always had the show with jazz so did
Jackie Chan getting rock hard though
when I watched it that's too much too in
the 90s I didn't realize how Jackie was
until I watched like Rumble in the Bronx
he was in good shape like dude he should
have showed that off more but I think he
was trying to play into the comedy side
but probably yeah I look like too much
of an obvious winner what's his name the
the guy that actor what's his name Van
Damme Van Damme movies my favorite was
the kickboxer one yeah
these movies were just like it just I
don't know it was barges hit different
kickboxer hits different yeah I just
believed he was an ultimate badass yeah
every Latino dad or at least my dad
would always watch it
I'm kick his ass and I used to tell him
like he but they used to be like you
don't think you can kick my ass and I'm
like yeah Dad [__] him you're like
you're like four foot nine
and then he just is like [__] like
I'll cook his ass
[Laughter]